Hi, I'm Ornella, and that's Joel, and we
built Ace, a live AI voice tutor.
It run on a small model on purpose, and
I want to tell you more why that's not a
compromise.
Quick gut check.
That silence on a voice call, that the
difference between a tutor and a broken
up.
When a voice agent pause for even a
second, your brain says it's dead.
So, when the answer fit a leader of
every instant stay, which for the
smallest, biggest model.
In voice, that instant is actually a
backward.
Because our budget was never IQ, it's
millisecond.
The AI model need to start talking in
about 950 milliseconds.
A frontier model that think for a full
second has already lost the room, no
matter how good the answer is.
So, we made the model small
and took the hardest part jobs away from
it.
It doesn't decide when happen what's
happen in the lesson.
It had It doesn't track what the student
knows.
It doesn't explain what's next. We have
a system in place to do that, and they
hand the model a summary every turn.
What's left for the model is one thing
it's really good at, talking.
And that's the theory. Joel, go on and
show them what it actually feel like.
>> Yeah, if maybe I can add some color to
what Ornella was mentioning.
So, if you think about the models of
today, especially the frontier model,
let's take Claude 4.7, which is uh from
Anthropic.
The model is really good at reasoning.
You can give it a problem, in this case
a lesson, and it can reason through it,
it can reason through what the student
asking and it can come up with the
answer.
But that is actually precisely the
problem.
Because the reasoning can take couple of
seconds and those seconds are really
valuable when you are building voice
applications.
So what we are doing is saying, "Hey,
let's extract all of the thinking away
from the model so that the model focuses
on only what matters, which is speaking
in our case."
So all of the thinking is extracted into
a state machine. So for Ace, we have
thought about all the scenarios that are
needed for a lesson. We have built a
state machine that is able to coordinate
each step to the next and we also added
intelligent layer on top to derive some
of the mastery that a student might need
for the lesson to be complete.
So everything when it comes to what
happens next, when it comes to what
needs to be displayed, when it comes to
how to actually answer a question, it's
all done outside of the model.
And we simply feed that output to the
model to speak out.
And so let's go ahead and look at an
example and see how that works in real
time.
So the first video here is without the
implementation we've done. So it's a
simple Opus 4.7. We ask a very simple
question and as you can see the model is
thinking, it's reasoning and it takes
couple of seconds to return the answer
back to the user. Hey, what In this
video, we've added all everything we
just talked about on Haiku 4.5, which is
a much smaller model.
Same question, but now you see that the
answer comes in about 900 milliseconds.
And so that's the beauty of building
around the model. So by removing all of
the thinking, all of the logic, all of
the reasoning from the model and
actually putting it within the code, we
actually saves a lot of time and allows
us to use smaller models which are cost
effective and actually better at
real-time voice applications. And as you
can see, this feels almost instant and
again that's because all of the smart
parts have already happened prior to the
model actually speaking.
But I have to be honest because this
isn't necessarily free. It has a cost,
right? A small model like the Haiku 4.5,
if it doesn't have any scaffolding, tend
to drift on long structure and really
needs strict rules in order to be able
to stay organized. So the scaffolding
piece is the price. But the good thing
is you pay it once and in code, right?
Not on every single turn.
So here's a rule.
Pick the fastest model that your latency
budget allows and then spend the rest of
your time actually building the
scaffolding. So [snorts] in our case,
right? Maybe you build a state machine,
you build a reasoning process, you think
about scenarios, what happens if this
happens, how should your model handle
it? Everything that comes with the
logic, everything that comes with the
harnessing, you do that outside of the
model and then allowing the model to
focus on that one thing that is really
good at. And so that's true for voice
applications like A is, that's true for
real-time applications where latency is
of priority and that's really true for
anything that is high volume, right? In
those cases, the model is the smallest
part of the system.
So this is Joel and Ornella and we are
building A is again and if you have any
questions, let us know. Thank you.
>> Thank you.